hey guys Ryan right here dance aberdeer
don't know why I was doing this is my
voice I have been told by many to watch
the trailer for the division mm-hmm
apparently this is a big one this is a
good one this is definitely on the list
of Dan buys yeah yeah it looks it looks
great okay so you seen it before
mm-hmm okay cool so you can't [ __ ]
anyone
I can't [ __ ] anyone now see he's
admitting he saw it before I've never
seen it I am here to add context and to
answer all of your questions okay why
are they saying there is content that
would be inappropriate for children
there are guns okay and there are
killing of people's okay is there nudity
no [ __ ] this game all right thanks for
watching
all right
hmm swing I love Christmas and that's
just makes me sad
it's hard to watch something you love
destroy itself to see it fall or
the company's Geographics a wild
detached someone else's struggle in some
faraway place it's not until it's in our
city and our doors that we realize how
fragile we are all of us all of this
let's get your ears
the one in here when it came down it
came down hard and we fell we buried
ourselves anger fear in the instinct to
survive
the truth is no one watched no one saw
like to see
tragedy is invisible people turn away
from it and run from it if they can and
it's hard knowing that you belong here
but your purpose lies oh oh yeah pain
but someone's gotta be there
whoosh
but the first piece back together
back together right back the [ __ ] off
I don't know why I get like a Dark
Knight Rises live woman it definitely
has that
you're
even the music a little bit D that's
chilling I know right
I was very gripping but let's face it
Tom Clancy oh cool yeah me this books me
good i I'm not sure if this is exactly
what if his books but oh god that
trailers yeah oh good no it's quite a
moving trailer like I who's weird I
started like turning up in the beginning
there yeah I'm like I don't even know
what's happening but it's is moving my
emotions right now it attacks you with
just like tugging at your heart strings
and at the very end just leaves with
this sort of inspiration of we're gonna
take back what's ours is just yeah yeah
then do you see the Dark Knight Rises
like resemblance a lot like after Bane's
takes over Gotham yes it's like there is
it has like the Snowy vibe and
everything and like the streets are
emptied in there yeah and the powerful
music it's cool it does look really cool
the basic story of this one is there's a
virus outbreak that's not zombies okay
which breaks from the mold as funny as
that is virus that essentially wipes out
like half of New York and in that chaos
like a government there breaks down and
eventually it became like these you know
bandits versus these guys trying to take
back the city oh cool yeah so oh I hear
there's a gameplay trailer
falling down just a little bit the world
so and still this is a refreshing take
on her there was Prior this was a little
more I up to live of course saw the
worst Christmas ever
oh of course I know where we are I'm
fitting the waypoint to the face
check your mouth Oh looks like it's
pretty close
hey follow me this way I love what
they're doing with like the new HUD so
it's not like it looks more integrated
with the environment than other games
have been
I know exactly coming here I know you do
in the last train out
like everybody panic
what kind of technology - they're on
video game technology the best kind they
do how do they are they've access
although I don't know
I want it whatever it is want you step
there you are hey guys I brought Chris
hey Chris hey okay we're about to unlock
my face it's up here on the right that's
on lottery base yeah yeah I start
shooting
kill mall just kill him shoot him in his
face what are we gonna do leads by the
base this is really cool
like you get a [ __ ] apocalyptic vibe
of New York City go toe-to-toe humans
hey you're in the game I'm in the game
oh boy left here yes good to go
oh good yeah here we go is that the game
talking or is that other players talking
that's actually other players time these
are players talking yeah it was really
confusing for a long time this would be
a fun online Wow
damn this looks really fun oh yeah I
love that that's like a tool you gay
it's just a dude that goes over a strobe
light dude wish this was kind of real oh
yes well yes I'm like you just want to
be that yeah I want to be that dude I
just don't want to be like whoa I missed
that what I was
we gotta move up for it last one keep
the pressure on
I spoke to these characters are badass
yeah I love the place of my friends
Wow
very impressive it looks fun it looks
very impressive that is the word for
this definitely it like some of the like
gadgets and tools you get in this thing
are incredibly inventive yeah just I
would say impressive mm-hmm it's a
definitely one that I hope that everyone
would check out and it is really
confusing because like half the time you
think it's like in-game like the
characters in the game talking to you
yeah and then like halfway through the
trailer you realize no one would ever
say that in that scenario ever yeah that
was cool that was really cool man the
gameplay looks like a lot of fun I like
how it's not Call of Duty again yeah
right hey they got it it has that like
sneaking around type of vibe but it's
gonna be a lot of gun play that's cool
my love games like that man it's gonna
be a good game a real energy really
exciting for it well guys thanks for
telling us about this if you're new to
this channel subscribe thank you thank
you and if you need a seen Dan subscribe
thank you Hey whoopee bed basically
tells the difference between your
channel in my jam
SOTA screw live drive it subscribe and
rule is 'red what's up you say give me a
shoutout welfare wizard she's just like
create a shout out or something god I
get it cuz he's a [ __ ] witch I got it
[ __ ] wizards wizards
Riki shout out spells at us but yeah
like he wants harry potter new
broomsticks flying broomsticks and I
watched a Harry Potter movie these
witches make it awkward for me Brian
Brennan hey can i have a shout out i
love you guys smiley face
yeah yeah I'm sure that I'm sure
there goes flush how about beautiful oh
there's a plane coming oh there's a
plane coming
oh no get away we tried man we tried was
this you PSF instead you know we should
start an improv troupe James God Bing
Goodman I look God babe got it
I am God bein the evolution I mean I
hope that is your real name because
that's badass
I need a [ __ ] shout out you need to
shout out it give me the best shout out
ever by the way your channel is awesome
best shout-out ever show me your dog